welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and you now locked
into the channel where we've been
watching The Watchmen to break down
everything that you need to know about
the new season on HBO throughout this
video we'll be recapping the fourth
entry in the series this fall and
discussing where the show could be
heading in the future there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch episode 4 yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of
Watchmen episode 4 ok so just a quick
recap to bring you up to speed on
everything so far on Watchmen that
sister Knight has uncovered what looks
like it could be a huge conspiracy
inside the police department that
seemingly shows one of its high ranking
officers was linked with a group known
as the 7th cavalry that carried out
attacks on the police and public after
this officer captain Jude was murdered
it drew the attention of the FBI who
sent in their agent at Laurie Blake in
order to investigate the crime episode
four picks up very much in the midst of
this with the cold war on the seventh
Cavalry and it also introduces many
aspects of the show that we've only
really had a lip service paid to so far
like most of the episodes we get a cold
opening that shows us a childless couple
that live in Oklahoma being woken in the
middle of the night by lady true who
wishes to offer them a child in exchange
for 40 acres of their land for those who
don't know true actually purchased
adrian veidt's businesses and
corporations before he went missing or
as we know off to the castle true
divulges that she has created a child
for the couple from their biological
material which he cultivated from one of
their clinics the couple don't want to
sell because their legacy is in their
land but as they don't have any kids
this won't be the case true has an
awesome introduction and she instantly
becomes one of the standout characters
in the show this fall at the home we see
what appears to be throughs daughter but
it is possible that she is also a
genetic creation and someone that has
been engineered by the character in
order to provide her with the legacy
that she so desperately wants to bring
to this family during the DLO something
crashes to earth and this becomes a big
question in the episode that we don't
get closure on we then join Angela who
with Lori and the FBI hot on our toes
begins to do a major cleanup of her
bakery including breaking down wills
wheelchair which becomes a big story
point later on it is revealed that will
can actually walk and that he has been
feigning his disability I'll discuss
this further in the recap but it is
important as it shows his similarities
with Angela who too has been pretending
to be a lowly Baker in order to avoid
suspicion and attention when cleaning up
the mess Angela overhears a voicemail
from the DNA center that states that
will and therefore her grandfather has
had an extra branch added to their
family tree returning nashi lens of
wills past and his mother and father as
well as the ordeal that he went through
as a child
it's where the series started and this
inclusion in Episode four makes her feel
like everything is slowly starting to
come full circle
however Angela doesn't want too much to
do with the character and after hearing
a large bang she runs outside to see
Lori where we left her last week with
Angela's car right in front of her I
love the fact that similar to last week
she's laughing maniacally as this ties
in a lot with her father the comedian
who is known for finding the humor in
destruction and shock the to have
another tense conversation and this
comes to a head later when Lorie takes
over Judds office in the police
department without asking for permission
it's clear that Lori is keeping a close
eye on the character and she's not the
only one when disposing of wills
wheelchair she is tracked by loop and I
mean spandex man I don't want to get
demonetized
anyway he certainly is a slippery
character and shows just how weird
Watchmen can be it looks like this is
Agent P T due to his height weight and
so on and his sudden appearance makes a
lot of sense as he arrived on the scene
not long after Lori and also has a
fascination with Angela who as we know
is a target for the both of them we also
learn more about the squid fall and how
like the original hoax attack by
Ozymandias they appear and then died not
long after those who are familiar with
the source material will know that these
creatures aren't really alive and after
seeing the suspicions surrounding the
squid attack in the first episode I
believe that the government or perhaps
even dr. Manhattan may be carrying out
these in order to keep up appearances to
stop the world from going back to war
anyway Angela also described
with Looking Glass hoods cause a costume
and LG seems to be on judge side about
it
he doesn't seem all that shocked either
and I definitely think that this guy may
secretly be in on it perhaps even behind
the attack on Judd because I'm not too
sure we'll would have carried it out in
the build-up to Jed's death we did see
strobe lights flicker and lookingglass
did use visual stimuli when
interrogating the cavalry member earlier
in episode 1 after going back to the
police station Laurie and Angela head
out to true industries in order to
investigate why Angela's car dropped
from the sky
Laurie shows that she's tightening the
net on Angela and reveals she visited
her husband and also discusses the
trauma in Angela's past that causes her
to dress up like a nun it's here that we
get to learn of Laurie's past and whilst
the two are currently at a standoff I
think it's becoming clear that they will
eventually team up and end up becoming
allies and this conversation shows the
commonality that they have with one
another this episode is really about
inheritance and just in the same way
that Laurie inherited being a masked
vigilante from her parents angela has
inherited unwanted things from her
grandfather will as well in addition to
this the introduction of the episode two
touched upon this motif with the family
possibly leaving nothing to inherit as
they had no heirs and overall this piece
showcases that everyone in the show is
in some way paying the ways for
quote-unquote the sins of their father
watchmen has always been very much about
the past and how it impacts the future
and this aesthetic is at its strongest
in this episode at the corporation at
throughs daughter gives Angela and
Laurie it to her I don't know what went
on here because there was no men allowed
and this is some SJW walk bullcrap now
they go there and be true and I told
that the giant clock there true is
building tells time true says that she
comes from Vietnam I actually have a
theory that this may potentially be the
comedian's daughter the characters
seemingly killed at the time by shooting
her mother when she was pregnant with
her I may be jumping the gun a bit but
the Vietnam callback definitely stands
out for me and in the original source
material though it was stipulated that
dr. Manhattan did nothing during this
killing as a way to show his detachment
from humanity it was a real later in the
book that he did care about
on some level due to micro-expressions
that showcased and after the comedian
departed he may have saved the child
this elixir could have been given
because he saw just how important true
was and the clock that she is building a
similar to Manhattan may have the
ability to view time simultaneously this
is all just my theory though so if you
disagree or agree with me then make sure
you leave your thoughts in the comment
section below true is aware of will and
it looks like she is the one that
rescued him and is keeping him safe
invites story we see him fishing in a
lake and pulling out babies that
eventually become the clown's that serve
Him we see him throwing some back
possibly because like the Buffalo in the
prior episode he is only allowed a
certain quota and if he passes this it
will draw the attention of the game
warden I've already made a full video on
Ozymandias plan and what I think it is
so yeah make sure you check that out
after this breakdown if you haven't yet
in short though I think that he is
trapped and trying to build a means of
escape with the clones Ozymandias is
clearly going stir-crazy though and
though he's murdered all of the clones
that does turn out to be a purpose for
this he has done it in order to create
ammo for the catapult in the episode we
see that he is testing it to see whether
it will fire beyond the barrier of his
home and it seems to be successful he
built the suit in the last episode
because outside of the barrier is the
cold reaches of an inhospitable planet
and thus he must have a suit that can
survive this we also learned that he's
been there for four years so it's not
the groundhog day situation that I've
seen some people say that it is it does
look like he could be on the moon but I
guess that we'll find out more as the
series goes on originally I thought this
was dr. Manhattan's work but I think now
that true has trapped him and did this
after buying the company we know that
she definitely can create babies and her
chamber in the episode shows that she
can change environments and it's
definitely within her wheelhouse back on
earth Cowell and Angela discuss will and
how the former is having difficulty
trusting Angela when she is clearly
hiding something similar to this back at
Tru industries daughter Tru has a dream
of being in a village that men burned
this is clearly a memory of trues
childhood and it adds more weight to the
fact that I think she is a clone of true
that has been created in order to carry
on her legacy we see well safe and sound
and it's revealed that he can indeed
walk it's becoming clear that he is
weaving this mystery for Angela in order
to allow her to unearth everything
slowly rather than dropping it on her
all at once we don't know what the ins
and outs are just yet but something is
clearly building and now this episode
seems predominantly set up it is very
intriguing
there is the tease of a climax with will
revealing that Angela will learn the
truth shortly and end up paying him for
it now going forward it looks like we
are finally going to get some backstory
for looking glass as well as what his
true motives are it appears that he may
be infiltrating the cavalry or that he
could already be a member personally I
think it's the latter and this episode
will be more of a showcase of his time
before the police and how he ended up
becoming part of their ranks now he may
not be it's just some things I've seen
over the episodes kind of paint him out
as a shady character either way it looks
like he isn't too big of a fan of Laurie
and she may be going face to face with
him at some point which the preview for
next week is clearly pointing towards it
also looks like Ozzy may finally escape
his prison and we will get some answers
towards what's going on with the
character so I'm very hard to see what
happens with him and if we finally learn
where he is obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on this episode and if you
agree with the theories in the video
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this then please give it a
thumbs up and don't forget to check out
my Ozymandias plan breakdown as well as
the series so far which would be linked
at the end we also do a podcast called
watching The Watchmen in which we break
down every issue of The Watchmen graphic
novel page by page and also give our
thoughts on Doomsday Clock I'll leave
that linked at the end and if you want
to come chat to me after the video that
makes you follow me on twitter at
definition YT or head over to my discord
server which would be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box set on
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming Ragnarok and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on Watchmen in
the comments section below the winners
gonna be chosen on the 15th of November
and the Cell be shipped out from then to
ever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition he's been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]